mardi en fin de journée au centre ville
de boston
pas difficile de trouver son chauffeur
hubert x la région en compte 10000 angel
mercedes transporte des passagers pour
hubert depuis six mois question de faire
un peu d'argent
hubert est devenu très populaire dit il
on utilise presque partout au
massachussetts seulement septembre il y
a eu dans l'état 2 millions de voyages
hubert principalement à boston un record
l'entreprise qui est installée ici
depuis trois ans allez-y lui de son côté
il y a un an
l'ex gouverneur deval patrick a émis une
directive permettant aux compagnies
comme hubert d'opérer même si aucune
réglementation ne les encadrent encore
au printemps la ville de boston a
commencé sa collaboration avec hubert
pour boston spéciquement eu des ententes
particulières qui ont été pris avec la
ville notamment sur le partage de
données
donc on partage un confidentiel dans le
belize et d'améliorer le service de
transport en commun la signalisation
routière des choses qu'on est
définitivement ouvert à faro post on a
aussi mis sur pied un comité pour
réformer l'industrie du taxi et du
transport de passagers
hubert en fait partie
le maire world cheveux permettent à ce
genre de compagnie d'exister le
directeur du comité il veut offrir des
transports diversifie à boston à la
veille de thanksgiving devant sound
station ce matin des dizaines de taxis
faisait la file pour offrir leurs
services aux bostoniens
les passagers qui attendaient hubert
semblait plus nombreux c'est là que nous
avons rencontré la porte parole du
syndicat des taxis
je suis frustré dit elle et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la ville ne fait
rien pour contrôler les prix ou
restreindre le nombre de véhicules
hubert à boston personne ne propose de
faire payer un permis de taxi à chaque
chauffeur hubert x l'état du
massachusetts étudie actuellement quatre
projets de loi qui priorise plutôt une
meilleure vérification des antécédents
criminels des chauffeurs une
identification de leur véhicule une
assurance adéquate et un permis
intermédiaire spéciale pour hubert un de
ces projets de loi seraient plus
contraignant car il forcerait chaque
chauffeur hubert à payer une assurance
commercial de 5000 $ par année
mais personne ici ne croit qu'il sera
adopté
jean-sébastien vous êtes toujours à
boston ya d'autres exemples en amérique
où les villes tentent de faire la paix
avec hubert je savais hubert est riche
hubert et puissante le fait beaucoup de
lober et elle est très populaire à la
fin du reportage quand je vous dis qu'un
projet de loi qui serait plus
contraignant pour rubin on croit pas que
ça passera ici hubert a déjà menacé de
quitter le massachussetts a passé et les
élus ne veulent pas nécessairement
salert autant on finit souvent par
s'entendre avec l'entreprise même par
exemple dans des villes comme san
antonio texas hubert avait quitté est
revenu c'est entendu en amérique du nord
aujourd'hui 67 et à ouville ont conclu
une entente avec hubert je le sais tu
écoutais le dg directeur général du
beurre pour le québec
chicago ici à tôt par exemple une taxe
spéciale qui était mis sur toutes les
courses d'à peu près 20 soudan par
course
on verse au gouvernement après ça
partout aux états unis ou dans le
plupart des villes il ya ce qu'on
appelle le thème na li ninety
l'équivalent d'un t4 pour travailleurs
autonomes qui est remis au gouvernement
à la fin de chaque année des choses
qu'on est ouvert à discuter si on prend
le canada plus près de nous toronto est
sur le point de vendre et
d'augmentations cargo et 13 ans
également le votre bosse passent au mois
de décembre dans lequel il revoit gamal
a fait de l'augmentation dans
l'industrie du taxi
alors voilà patrice faudra voir si le
ministère des transports québec et
l'entreprise s'entendront au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
jusqu où hubert est prête à aller
jusqu'où québec est prêt à aller et as
pour que ça pénalise pas non plus trop
l'industrie du taxi je peux vous dire en
tout cas qu'on se parle depuis quelques
semaines très bien merci au revoir